foreign
[Music]
thank you
86 dollars for half a tank
we are going to Yosemite
[Music]
foreign
actually probably higher because I just
passed that sign a little while ago
still climbing I think this is the
highest Bay it's ever been Tioga Pass
could close any day now because there's
there's snow all around here right now
and it got so cold last night it was
well I checked the weather
um around 1am and it was 17 degrees so
definitely had the heater on last night
but oh and my windows froze shut I
couldn't open that this morning this is
my first time taking van to Yosemite one
of my friends scored campsites at
Campground and there's space for two
rigs at least that's what it says online
we're hoping we can both fit there
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
I could live here
[Music]
I think maybe if this filmmaking thing
doesn't work out for me I'm just gonna
quit and become a park ranger if they'll
have me
returning to Yosemite will always feel a
bit like returning to a dream
I didn't even know it existed until I
was 28 but since then I've found myself
returning here again and again
this is where I snow shoot for the very
first time and pitched a tent in five
degree weather with friends
this is where my 241 mile Trek along the
John Muir Trail began
Where I Stood on top of Half Dome
followed beautiful Trails into the
unknown and Campton places that didn't
even feel real
[Music]
I've been here with friends with
Partners colleagues and I've stood here
alone more times than I can count
I've been here through spring summer
winter and fall when the waterfalls were
raging and when there was no water at
all
I've wandered this Valley in the snow
the rain the wind the Sun the smoke
so many sunsets sunrises and just nights
spent beneath the stars
[Music]
[Applause]
in the shadow of these Granite walls
I've learned from and been inspired by
people who've turned their own dreams
into reality
and I still have to remind myself at
times that this is not a dream
[Music]
thank you
I haven't decided
[Music]
in the forest
foreign
[Music]
thank you
tonight it's supposed to get down to 11
degrees which is going to be
really cool
last night it was really cold and I
think it only got down to like 20s when
I woke up I couldn't turn on my heater
because my battery was completely
flatlined I am driving around the park
right now just trying to rejuvenate my
house batteries and it's supposed to
snow in the next hour and a half
the last time I was in Yosemite it was
the day before it started snowing for
the first time and it was like a huge
winter storm being in the Xterra I felt
totally safe having a 4x4 that I could
navigate the roads just fine but I
didn't have a heater and I didn't have
insulation so pros and cons they have
closed Tioga Road they say temporarily
closed 120 in preparation for the snow
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
the storm is moving in that happened
kind of fast I was making soup but I
think I should get out of here because
it's snowing and I'm up at tunnel view
which means I still got like 25 minute
drive back to Camp it's getting dark and
I don't want to be stuck on slippery
roads so
um my soup is cooked but
I have it on the floor that's probably
not going to go well but I figured it
was better than sitting here and eating
it and driving back in the dark so
fingers crossed the suit makes it
[Music]
soup is still holding on strong I can
smell it
[Music]
made my soup I got avocado and then I
toasted some sourdough bread with olive
oil and sea salt I'm gonna eat dinner
and then I don't know because I'll
probably run out of power uh if I plug
in my laptop and work I really want to
review footage and edit but sometimes
this is one of the reasons why I fall so
far behind on videos because when I'm
inspired to edit I don't always have
enough power to edit so I have to find
other things to do and tonight is
probably going to be one of those nights
anyway I will see you guys in the
morning
[Music]
foreign